for Palestinian children history isn't
just learned from the pages of a school
textbook it is the memories and stories
their mothers fathers and grandparents
ensure they never forget it is their
experiences living under Israeli
occupation Muhammad Abu al-abad who's in
the 10th grade is also learning about
how history can be Rewritten
it teaches me that if something like
this happens in the future not to keep
silent or think this is normal I have to
protest like I am now and stand against
the occupation
in July the Israeli education Ministry
revoked the permanent licenses of six
Palestinian schools in occupied East
Jerusalem the education Minister
declined our request for an interview
but in a statement she says the schools
are using textbooks that glorify
prisoners arms struggle against Israel
and their teaching incitement the
schools have one year to remove the
books or they'll be closed it's like an
authoritarian regime that wants to wipe
parts of that truth from its his own
people and this is happening to seven
years old children this is ridiculous
and we will not allow that since the
1975 order the Palestinian Authority has
overseen the education of its people
we contacted the donors of the
educational sector and the International
Community to urge them to take action
and stop this attack against Palestinian
educational system in Jerusalem one of
the attorneys representing the school
says this is politically motivated
censorship that breaches the 1995 Oslo
Accords and international laws on
occupation the basic and most common
rule in international law regarding
occupied territories whereas the
occupant could never Rule and occupied
territory with sovereignty
since one of the main and most inherent
instruments of sovereignty is dictation
of Education
the legal team representing the schools
admits the prospects of prevailing in
the Israeli judicial system are slim
these Palestinians say at stake is the
Erasure of their Heritage and identity
Natasha gname Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem